[Musique]
ce vendredi 16 juillet l'humiliation de
l'exposition résonances le louvre à la
réunion un partenariat entre le musée du
louvre la direction des affaires
culturelles le département et la région
réunion
ce sont deux cent trente six dessins
prêtés gracieusement dans le prestigieux
musée du louvre qui expose pour la
première fois dans les outre mer la
collaboration entre les musées de la
réunion les cinq musées de la réunion
qui sont des musées de france et le
musée du louvre s'est mis en place il ya
maintenant plus de deux ans et demi et
le but était de pouvoir montrer aux
visiteurs de la réunion comment
finalement les collections du musée de
la réunion pouvait être entré en réunion
en résonance avec les collections du
musée du louvre
donc nous avons invité chacun des
directeurs conservateur des cinq musées
de la réunion le musée léon dierx le
muséum d'histoire naturelle le musée de
villèle le musée stella matutina et le
musée des arts décoratifs de l'océan
indien à venir finalement faire un choix
dans nos collections et essayer de faire
dialoguer
les collections du louvre avec leur
collection
ce voyage du louvre ici à la réunion
avec cette mixité d'oeuvres venant du
louvre et d'oeuvre jeudi issus des
musées régionaux et départementaux
les musées de france delà des cinq
musées de france de la réunion quand je
trouve que c'est un c'est un mariage
c'est une résidence extraordinaire et
j'ai vraiment trouvé que l'exposition
résonances mérité parfaitement son nom
c'est vraiment un beau symbole que nous
vivons aujourd'hui à la réunion
pour le président du département il
s'agit là d'une opération de
démocratisation de la culture
c'est un moyen aussi pour nos de lancer
une opération de démocratisation
je dirais de la culture parce que ici
même des marmailles près de 3000
marmailles de la réunion se sont
inscrits déjà quoi visiter donc cette
exposition le département participe
instant la région aussi nous voulons
faire en sorte que alors même qu' à
cette crise sanitaire qui nous
pénalisent qui m'ont bhl qui rend le
monde culturel parfois inaccessibles eh
bien nous voulons aller vers les
réunionnais en leur proposant ces belles
oeuvres venues de paris une exposition
exceptionnelle qui a nécessité des
aménagements pour la réunion qui se
trouve en milieu tropical
il a fallu évidemment
gérer au plus près les conditions
d'hygrométrie les conditions de
luminosité dans les musées nous avons
fait suivant les normes qui sont celles
des règles de l'art en lien étroit avec
le musée du louvre
nous savions déjà le faire mais nous
sommes 3 3 musées qui sont labellisés
musées de france qui conserve des
collections qui sont très très fragile
mais nous avons été encore plus pointu
plus exigeants s'agissant des oeuvres
que nous accueillons et pour lesquels
nous devons prendre aucun risque
l'exposition résonances sera visible
dans les cinq musées de l'île jusqu'au
15 octobre prochain
[Musique]